nous on était une structure sans joueur
et eux étaient des joueurs qui cherchent
une structure donc c'est un match est
tout de suite entre nous
[Musique]
notre situation argile c'est que ce club
centenaire 102 ans cette année elle est
devoir arrêter avec l'inquiétude de ces
dirigeants puisque il manquait de
joueurs et grâce aux migrants qui se
situent sur Buzançais sur Châteauroux
l'un d'entre eux a proposé de venir avec
ses collègues intéressés par le foot et
sur Argi cette nationalité
s'entraîne avec les bénévoles d'argile
c'est très beau
tu en voulais ouvrir un club mais vu
qu'il fallait
tous les matériels déjà emplacements
l'argent tout ça et tout on n'avait pas
ça bah quand j'ai entendu que les clubs
allaient se fermer bon j'ai parlé avec
les gars j'ai dit bah en fait j'ai une
proposition à vous faire il y a ce club
qui va se fermer est-ce que ça vous dit
[Musique]
on n'a pas eu de difficultés à
s'intégrer à communiquer avec
les joueurs qui étaient déjà là pour
l'ancienne baptiser et là actuellement
on communique on s'amuse on dirait une
petite famille il y a pas de problème on
sort personne qui sait sans savoir d'où
tu viens ou tu es de quelle couleur il y
a pas ça dans l'équipe en fait
[Musique]